aquí tenemos algo que muchos de ustedes
han experimentado alguna vez este es un
auto que está pasando por una curva con
una rapidez constante sobre un camino
plano no está inclinado como las pistas
de carreras que es lo que hace que el
auto siga la curva y no salga disparado
en línea recta esto es un poco menos
intuitivo porque no tenemos una cuerda
atada al auto y que éste a su vez atada
al centro del círculo que es lo que
mantiene al auto en la trayectoria curva
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en ello
veamos las fuerzas que están actuando
sobre el auto y de nuevo imaginemos que
esto ocurre en el vacío por lo que no
hay resistencia al aire aunque si
hubiera resistencia al aire la fuerza
que la equilibra es la fuerza de
fricción aquí tenemos la fuerza de
gravedad que jala el auto hacia abajo
esta fuerza es contrarrestada por la
fuerza normal ejercida por el camino
sobre el auto pensándolo bien incluyamos
la resistencia al aire sólo por
diversión
la resistencia al aire va a empujar al
auto hacia atrás o hacia la dirección
opuesta a la dirección de la velocidad
del auto la denominamos efe aire y esta
fuerza es equilibrada
por la fuerza de fricción esto es algo
poco intuitivo pero nos da una pista
sobre la fuerza centrípeta la fuerza de
fricción la denominamos efe mayúscula
subíndice f y tiene la misma dirección
que la del auto cómo funciona esto sí
imagina en este auto sobre hielo las
ruedas no tendrán tracción no importaría
que tanto trabaje el motor ni qué tan
rápido giren las ruedas el auto no podrá
superar la resistencia al aire y el auto
va a desacelerar estas no son todas las
fuerzas que actúan sobre el auto en la
dirección radial y que lo mantienen en
movimiento en esta trayectoria circular
la fuerza que falta es nuevamente la
fuerza de fricción o mejor dicho otro
componente de la fuerza de fricción esta
fuerza ocurre cuando las llantas tocan
el camino esta es la fuerza de fricción
radial y es la que mantiene a este auto
en la trayectoria circular en esta
situación esta es la fuerza centrípeta
veamos otro ejemplo pero sigamos con el
tema de los autos aquí tenemos un camino
con rizo vertical lo cual siempre es
divertido y da algo de miedo a veces
sueño que tengo que conducir mi auto en
uno de estos rizos y la verdad es algo
que me intimida bastante
pero pensemos en qué le ocurre a este
auto en diversos puntos del rizo cuál es
la fuerza centrípeta que actúa sobre el
auto en diferentes puntos primero veamos
este punto de aquí de nuevo supongamos
que esto está en un planeta por lo que
está actuando la fuerza de gravedad
también está la fuerza normal que voy a
dibujar más grande ya que para que el
auto se mantenga en este rizo vertical
la fuerza neta hacia adentro debe ser
mayor así que la fuerza normal es más
grande en este caso la magnitud de la
fuerza centrípeta es la fuerza radial
interna que corresponde a la magnitud de
la fuerza normal menos la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad si esta fuerza neta
no tuviera una dirección hacia adentro
este auto no podría moverse en una ruta
circular si esto fuera igual a cero el
auto se movería en línea recta y si esto
fuera negativo el auto se movería hacia
abajo ahora veamos qué pasa en este
punto de acá en este caso también
podríamos incluir la resistencia al aire
que tendría esta dirección y la fuerza
de fricción la superaría en la dirección
contraria pero vamos a enfocarnos
solamente en las fuerzas que nos llevan
centrípeta hacia adentro o hacia afuera
de esta trayectoria circular en este
otro punto seguimos teniendo la fuerza
de gravedad pensándolo bien siempre si
vamos a incluir la resistencia al aire y
la fuerza de fricción en el punto de
abajo dibujamos la resistencia al aire
que está siendo superada por la fuerza
de fricción ocasionada por la atracción
de las ruedas sobre la pista regresando
a este punto este vector es una
combinación de la fuerza de gravedad más
la resistencia al aire esta fuerza
empuja hacia atrás al auto debido a la
presión del aire esto es equilibrado por
la fuerza de fricción entre las ruedas y
la pista pero ninguna de estas fuerzas
está actuando en la dirección centrípeta
que fuerza actúa radialmente hacia
adentro aquí tenemos la fuerza normal de
esta pista esta pista es lo que mantiene
a este auto en una trayectoria circular
así que la fuerza radial hacia adentro
es la fuerza normal la magnitud de la
fuerza centrípeta es igual a la magnitud
de la fuerza normal y coincide que son
los mismos vectores ahora veamos este
último punto cuando estamos en el punto
más alto del rizo
en el vídeo y traten de encontrar las
fuerzas que están actuando aquí de nuevo
podemos dibujar la resistencia al aire
que trata de desacelerar este auto esta
fuerza es contrarrestada por la fuerza
de fricción pero qué pasa en la
dirección vertical en dirección hacia
abajo podemos tener varias fuerzas una
de ellas es la fuerza de gravedad cuales
otras fuerzas podemos tener suponiendo
que el auto tiene la rapidez suficiente
la pista también ejerce una fuerza sobre
el auto con dirección hacia abajo así
que esto es la fuerza de gravedad más la
fuerza normal la magnitud de este vector
es igual a la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad más la magnitud de la fuerza
normal esto es lo que proporciona la
fuerza centrípeta lo escribimos también
sucede lo mismo con los vectores de
estas fuerzas si sumamos estos dos
vectores tendremos el vector de la
fuerza centrípeta que es lo que mantiene
a este auto en esta trayectoria circular
veamos un último escenario sólo por
diversión aquí tenemos un planeta puede
ser cualquiera y tiene un satélite en
órbita lo dibujaré como nos conocemos en
la tierra pero que podría ser un sat
y te natural como la luna aquí no hay
aire por lo que no hay resistencia al
aire este satélite se mueve en una
trayectoria circular uniforme alrededor
de este planeta que es lo que evita que
se mueva en línea recta pausa en el
vídeo y piensen en ello aquí tenemos la
fuerza de gravedad del planeta y quizá
les llame la atención que aquí haya una
fuerza de gravedad pues es posible que
hayan visto imágenes de astronautas
flotando cuando están en órbita bueno
eso es porque están en caída libre pero
la gravedad no es tan diferente cuando
estamos a cientos de kilómetros por
arriba de la superficie del planeta aquí
no hay aire y si se está en órbita se
está en una caída libre constante y es
por eso que da la impresión de que no
existe la gravedad pero es la gravedad
lo que mantiene al satélite en órbita o
en trayectoria circular alrededor del
planeta y es lo que evita que el
satélite salga disparado en línea recta
hacia el espacio
nos vemos en otro vídeo